This is gonna be more matches
than I have ever or will ever use.
You think so?
Yeah, this is like-
I guess you don't smoke, or-
fifty lifetimes
worth of matches.
Is it?
Yeah, you're probably right.
Hello there, lovely internet.
I'm Gavin.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
Dan, we're doing a match bomb.
Yep!
I've got here in my hand about
three hours worth of work.
It's about 6,000 match heads
we've chopped off here,
and they're stuck in this saucepan.
It took a really long time.
The MythBusters did this with, I think,
a million match heads.
Yeah, I'm not going to sit there
to do a million, 6,000 is enough, I think.
Yeah, I think they had
a few more employees
to help out with the match heads,
Yeah.
But.
I saved one match.
What we're gonna do is chuck it in there,
and watch as it all goes
up at the same time.
Hopefully they'll combust
and leap up out of the air,
spinning, burning and
making a quite a high flame.
Don't try this at home, probably.
Okay, you just gotta be, very careful.
Oh!
Oh God, this is harder than it looks.
Why didn't we get
a pouring saucepan?
Why didn't we get funnel?
We didn't think Think
about this at all, did we?
Oh God, they're going everywhere!
All my work going into this here.
Hey lovely, lovely.
So we got the Phantom
Flex 4k doing a wide.
We got a tight on the Phantom Flex.
Whew! Let's see how it goes.
Yeah.
I'm nervous.
Well, me too.
Three hours work, here.
Okay, you ready?
Let me just black reference.
Alright.
No, not yet, it's just,
it's above the matches.
Well that's 'cause you put it
on the top like that.
There you go, watch out! Watch out!
Whoa!
Man!
Oh!
Careful, careful, careful.
Ah, it smells so good.
Whoa!
They look like ants that are burning,
Yeah.
trying to escape something,
saying, "Get me out of here!"
"Get me out of this blender."
That's crazy,
the amount that are just
flying out of there.
That looks so weird.
That's cool, it's like,
it's literally raining fire.
It's crazy that the fire, the matches
were literally lifted
out of the container.
Yeah, what makes them lift up like that?
Is it just that they're so
light and the heat lifts them?
I guess so, yeah.
Like a hot air balloon.
Yeah, pretty much.
We may have given the leaves
a little bit of a char up there.
Well in that chaos was
some lovely slow motion.
Very pretty, actually.
And that's-
I think that's what we do best.
We find the beauty in the
dangerous and the chaotic.
That was pretty profound actually.
Yeah?
Quite impressed.
Just made it up on the spot.
That was good, yeah.
If you enjoyed that video,
feel free to subscribe.
You'll get an alert. Every
time we upload a video,
you can follow us on Twitter,
I wouldn't drink that.
I wouldn't even smell it to be honest.
I think it's poisonous.
Yeah, probably.
Not a great idea, I'm gonna put that down.
Yeah, pop it down.
Yeah.
You can also buy a shirt,
buy a Slow Mo shirt,
buy a Rooster Teeth shirt, it's all good.
Yeah.
Hopefully we'll see you
in the next video.
Sweet.